So this is what I've come up with.
I've used the font method on the context and set it to 36 point impact and
I've set the textAlign property on the context to center.
You didn't have to do this, but you'll see why this is cool in a second.
For the internal fillText, I set it to white.
Then I set the fillText to CANVAS MEMES!,
with an x position starting at half the width of the canvas and
a y position of 40.
This x position plus this text alignment of
center makes sure that our text is centered on the page.
Then for the strokes, I set the style to black,
I set the line width to 3, then I finish up with the strokeText method,
which takes in the same parameters as the fillText method from before.
Let's go ahead and save this and see how it looks.
Coming over to the browser, we see our Canvas Memes!,
with white text and a black outline.
Looks like we're ready to start making some memes.